Well, I hold in my hand a ghost story that comes from a publication that is not really known for its tales of the supernatural. I'm talking about the American Journal of Opthalmalogy, a medical journal. This is from a 1921 edition. And just in case your subscription lapsed during World War I, I'm just going to read from one of these articles.
我手里拿的是一个鬼故事，来自一份并不以刊登灵异故事而闻名的刊物。我指的是《美国眼科杂志》，这是一份医学期刊。这是1921年的一期。以防你在第一次世界大战期间停止了订阅，我打算读一下其中一篇文章。
This is a letter that a doctor sent in. It's from one of his patients, actually, this letter. She's identified as Mrs. H. And in the letter, she's describing a very strange series of events that happened to her and her family starting when they moved into a rambling old house on November 15, 1921. This house was out of repair, had no electricity. It was lit by gas lights-- a very gloomy house. Albert Donnay is the person who unearthed this article. And he agreed to come into the studio and read from Mrs. H's account of what happened to them.
这是一位医生寄来的一封信，其实是他的病人写的。她被标记为H太太。在信中，她描述了从1921年11月15日搬进一栋破旧的老宅开始，她和家人发生的一系列非常奇怪的事情。这栋房子年久失修，没有电，用的是煤气灯，非常阴森。阿尔伯特·多内是挖掘出这篇文章的人，他同意来到录音室，朗读H太太对所发生之事的记述。
"Mr. H and I had not been in the house more than a couple of days when we felt very depressed. The house was overpoweringly quiet. The servants walked about on thickly carpeted floors so quietly that I could not even hear them at their work."
“我和H先生住进那栋房子才两天，就感到非常压抑。房子里安静得令人窒息。仆人们在铺着厚地毯的地板上走动，声音轻得连他们干活时我都听不见。”
I love how no story of this era can be complete without servants padding about.
我喜欢那个时代，没有仆人们轻手轻脚走来走去的场景，故事就不完整。
And they had many servants. "One morning, I heard footsteps in the room over my head. I hurried up the stairs. To my surprise, the room was empty. I passed into the next room, and then into all the rooms on that floor, and then to the floor above, to find that I was the only person in that part of the house.
他们确实有很多仆人。“一天早上，我听到头顶的房间里有脚步声。我匆忙跑上楼。令我惊讶的是，房间里空无一人。我走进隔壁房间，然后是那一层所有的房间，再到楼上，发现那部分房子里只有我一个人。”
Sometimes after I've gone to bed, the noises from the store room are tremendous, as if furniture was being piled against the door, as if china was being moved about, and occasionally, a long and fearful sigh or a wail. Sometimes as I walk along the hall, I feel as if someone was following me, going to touch me. You cannot understand it if you've not experienced it. But it's real.
有时我上床睡觉后，储藏室里会传出巨大的响声，好像有人在把家具堆向门口，又好像瓷器被搬来搬去，偶尔还会传出一声长长而可怕的叹息或哀号。有时我沿着走廊走，感觉好像有人在跟着我，正要碰我。如果你没有亲身经历过，是无法理解的。但这是真的。
As I was dressing for breakfast one morning, B, who is four years old, came to my room and asked me why I'd called him. I told him I had not called him, that I had not been in his room. With big and startled eyes, he said, 'Who was it then that called me? Who made that pounding noise?' I told him it was undoubtedly the wind rattling his window. 'No,' he said, 'It was not that. It was somebody that called me. Who was it?' And so on he talked, insisting that he'd been called and for me to explain who it had been."
一天早上我正穿衣准备吃早餐，四岁的B来到我的房间，问我为什么要叫他。我告诉他我没叫过他，也没去过他的房间。他睁大惊恐的眼睛说：‘那刚才叫我的人是谁？是谁发出了那种砰砰声？’我告诉他那肯定是风在吹动他的窗户。‘不，’他说，‘不是那样的。是有人叫我。是谁呢？’他一直在说，坚持说有人叫他，还让我解释那个人是谁。”
It gets worse. The adults and the children are held down in their beds by unseen figures. Beds shake. The plants die, and their children feel weak. They have no energy. They get severe headaches.
情况更糟了。大人们和孩子们被看不见的身影按在床上。床在晃动。植物枯萎了，孩子们感到虚弱。他们没有任何精力，头痛剧烈。
"Some nights, after I'd been in bed for a while, I felt as if the bedclothes were jerked off me. And I've also felt as if I'd been struck on the shoulder. One night, I woke up and saw sitting on the foot of my bed a man and a woman. The woman was young, dark, and slight and wore a large picture hat. I was paralyzed and could not move."
“有些晚上，我躺下一会儿后，觉得床单好像被从我身上拽走了。我还感觉到好像被人打了一下肩膀。一天晚上，我醒来看到床尾坐着一男一女。那个女人很年轻，肤色黝黑，身材瘦削，戴着一顶巨大的装饰帽。我瘫痪了，动弹不得。”
And so finally, her brother-in-law comes to them, she writes, with a thought about what might be happening.
最后，她写道，她的内兄来找他们，对可能发生的事情有了一些想法。
Her husband's brother comes to them in January and says that perhaps they're being poisoned. He'd read a story about a family poisoned by gas who had similar curious delusions. And he advised them to see a professor about this at once.
她丈夫的兄弟在一月份来看他们，说他们可能中毒了。他读过一个家庭因煤气中毒而产生类似奇怪幻觉的故事。他建议他们立刻去看一位教授。
A quick investigation shows that the furnace is actually sending carbon monoxide fumes into the house, instead of up the chimney. They fix that, and the ghostly hauntings stop. They don't feel sick anymore either, which makes a lot of sense, says Albert Donnay. When he's not poking around old medical archives, he's an environmental health engineer and a toxicologist, who spends a lot of his time warning people about carbon monoxide seeping into homes. And he says fumes like this wouldn't just come from the furnace of an old house. The kind of gas that they used in gas lights in that area had as much carbon monoxide as a car's exhaust. And he says carbon monoxide gas can account for everything that this family experienced.
快速调查显示，炉子实际上是在把一氧化碳烟雾排放到房子里，而不是从烟囱排出去。他们修好了炉子，闹鬼事件就停止了。他们也不再感到不舒服了，阿尔伯特·多内说这很有道理。他不研究旧医学档案时，是一位环境健康工程师和毒理学家，他花很多时间警告人们注意渗入家中的一氧化碳。他说，这样的烟雾不仅仅来自旧房子的炉子。当时该地区煤气灯中使用的那种气体含有的一氧化碳含量与汽车尾气一样多。他说一氧化碳气体可以解释这个家庭经历的一切。
No question about it. Carbon monoxide poisoning can cause all manner of hallucinations-- audio, visual, feeling strange things on their skin when there was nothing there. People often report that they hear noises in their ears, bells ringing, rushing sounds.
毫无疑问。一氧化碳中毒会导致各种幻觉——听觉、视觉，以及在什么都没有的情况下感到皮肤上有奇怪的东西。人们经常报告说他们听到耳朵里有声音，有铃声，有奔涌的声音。
What's amazing about this story is what a completely traditional ghost story it is. I feel like everything that happens to them, I've heard in some ghost story at some point or another. And then it turns out to be carbon monoxide poisoning. And I gotta say, I can't tell if I feel sort of relieved that there's a totally rational explanation or kind of disappointed.
这个故事神奇之处在于它是一个多么传统的鬼故事。我觉得他们身上发生的一切，我在某个鬼故事里都听过。结果却是一氧化碳中毒。我不得不说，我不知道我是该因为有一个完全理性的解释而感到宽慰，还是感到失望。
I totally share that perspective. It's kind of disappointing to find that it's not some otherworldly explanation.
我完全同意这个观点。发现这不是什么超自然的解释，确实有点令人失望。
It is kind of like a killjoy story for Halloween.
这简直像个万圣节扫兴的故事。
I'm not going to go there.
我可不这么看。
Well, it's Halloween, and this little example shows you what kind of boring killjoy trouble you can get into when you start applying rationality and facts to a perfectly good scary story, a story that never wanted to hurt anyone. From WBEZ Chicago, it's a special Halloween edition of our show, which we're calling-- scary music cue, please-- And the Call Was Coming From the Basement.
好吧，今天是万圣节，这个小例子向你展示了当你开始用理性和事实去分析一个本可以很吓人的故事时，你会陷入多么无聊的扫兴麻烦中，一个本没想伤害任何人的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是我们节目的万圣节特别版，我们称之为——请配上恐怖音乐——《电话是从地下室打来的》。
These stories are all absolutely true. And carbon monoxide, or let me just say, any of your carbon-based gases figure not at all into any of them. Our show today in four scary acts, including the true scary stories that you and listeners like you called into our scary story hotline, and a story in which David Sedaris walks among the dead. Stay with us.
这些故事都是绝对真实的。一氧化碳，或者让我说，任何碳基气体，与它们毫无关系。我们今天的节目分为四个恐怖章节，包括你和像你一样的听众打进我们的恐怖故事热线讲的真实恐怖故事，以及大卫·塞达里斯在死者中行走的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, The Hills Have Eyes. Well, one kind of scary story is when something that usually is not dangerous becomes transformed. You know, when something fluffy or funny becomes murderous, like little dolls that come to life, or ventriloquist dummies, or clowns, or little woodland creatures. Alex Blumberg has one such absolutely true tale. He was a producer on our show back when we first ran this episode. Today's show is a rerun. Here's Alex.
第一幕，《隔山有眼》。嗯，有一种恐怖故事是当通常并不危险的东西发生了转变。你知道，当毛茸茸或有趣的东西变得残暴时，比如活过来的小玩偶，或者腹语木偶，或者小丑，或者林间小生物。亚历克斯·布隆伯格就有这样一个绝对真实的故事。他在我们首次播出这一集时是我们节目的制作人。今天的节目是重播。请听亚历克斯讲述。
Michelle and her husband lived in the woods at the end of a long, half mile driveway off a little-used dirt road. They loved it there, surrounded by trees and mountains but still only an hour and a half by train from New York City. One weekend morning, as was their custom, they went out for a short walk. It was a beautiful winter day, almost a foot of snow on the ground. They got to the road and turned around to head back up the drive.
米歇尔和她的丈夫住在一片树林里，在一条人迹罕至的土路旁，那是一条半英里长的车道的尽头。他们喜欢那里，四周被树木和群山环绕，但乘火车离纽约市只有一个半小时的路程。一个周末的早晨，照惯例，他们出门短途散步。这是一个美丽的冬日，地上积雪有一英尺深。他们走到路上，转身准备沿车道回走。
My husband tends to walk faster than I do, and he was wanting to sort of do a little jog. And I said, OK, then, why don't you just kind of go ahead? So he went on home, and I had just started on the driveway. And I looked down the straightaway, and I saw this animal that was pretty far down. And then I saw it. I said, oh, it looks like a raccoon.
我丈夫走路比我快，他想慢跑一下。我说，好吧，那你先走吧。于是他回家了，我才刚刚走上车道。我向直道望去，看到远处有一只动物。然后我看到了它。我说，哦，看起来像只浣熊。
I would say it was at least 150 to 200 feet. It was pretty far away. And I'm looking at it, and I'm thinking, well, it's going to go up into the woods. But it started walking towards me. And then I realized it hasn't seen me yet, and I sort of just waved my arm a little bit. And then all of a sudden, it sees me. And the second it was aware of me, it just bolted towards me. I mean, there wasn't a second of a hesitation. It was like, oh my god. It's like, oh my god. It's coming right at me.
我想至少有150到200英尺远。离得很远。我看着它，心想，好吧，它会跑进树林里的。但它开始向我走来。然后我意识到它还没看见我，我就随手挥了挥胳膊。突然，它看见我了。在它意识到我存在的那一秒，它立刻朝我冲了过来。我是说，没有半秒钟的迟疑。我当时想，天哪。天哪，它正向我冲过来。
I turned, and I started to run. I was trying to outrun it. And I kept turning to see if the animal was bearing down on me, and it was getting closer. And it was now within 5 or 10 feet behind me. And the whole time, I mean from the moment the raccoon saw me, it hissed and snarled. I mean, it was [HISSING]. The feeling was, all it cared about was attacking me.
我转身开始奔跑。我试图跑赢它。我不停地回头看那只动物是否在逼近我，它越来越近了。现在它离我身后只有5到10英尺了。整个过程中，我是说从浣熊看到我的那一刻起，它就一直在嘶嘶作响、咆哮。我是说，那感觉就是，它唯一的目的就是攻击我。
So I don't even know what I was thinking, but I ran off the drive, thinking, well, I'll get away from it. Well, as I run off the drive, it jumps onto my thigh, and I fall into the snow, kind of down behind a rock. And then the next thing I see is his mouth is around my right thigh.
所以我都不知道自己在想什么，我跑离了车道，心想，好吧，我会避开它的。结果，我刚跑出车道，它就跳到了我的大腿上，我摔倒在雪地里，倒在一块石头后面。接下来我看到的是它的嘴咬住了我的右大腿。
The raccoon was about 30 pounds. Michelle, a slight woman, was about 115. She was wearing a big parka and snow pants, so the raccoon wasn't able to get a good grip. Using all her body weight and both hands, she was able to pull it off her leg and pin it in the snow, away from her body.
那只浣熊大约有30磅重。米歇尔是个瘦弱的女性，大约115磅。她穿着厚重的派克大衣和滑雪裤，所以浣熊没能咬住要害。她用尽全身力气和双手，设法把它从腿上扯下来，按在雪地里，让它远离身体。
I'm pushing its face into the snow so that it would keep putting its head up and snarling. And then it would keep trying with its claws to scratch at me. But I kept leaning on it and then pushing it into the snow. And I'm screaming at the top of my lungs, "Help. Somebody help me. I'm being attacked." I mean, I'm just-- and I'm thinking, the closest neighbor, it's a house that they're sort of weekenders, and often, they're not there. And it seemed like no one was coming out of their house. And I'm a half a mile from my house. And I'm thinking, nobody is going to help me. And so it was after about five minutes, I stopped screaming. And I just started thinking, what am I going to do?
我把它的脸按进雪里，好让它不再抬头咆哮。它不停地试图用爪子抓我。但我一直压着它，把它往雪里按。我声嘶力竭地尖叫：“救命。有人救救我。我被攻击了。”我是说，我当时心想，最近的邻居住的是周末度假屋，他们经常不在。好像根本没人从屋里出来。离我家还有半英里远。我想，没人会来帮我了。大约五分钟后，我停止了尖叫。我开始想，我该怎么办？
This raccoon was behaving in a way that normal raccoons never behave, like it was possessed. And that's because in some sense, it was. It had rabies, a disease that even scientists who study it called diabolical. It's a virus that attacks the aggression centers of the brain. It switches off all an animal's natural inhibitions, including fear and pain. At the same time, it floods the animal's body with adrenaline, making it stronger and more relentless. Animals which are normally shy and easily scared away turn into tireless, ferocious monsters. They become nothing but a vehicle for the virus, attacking anything that moves in order to spread the disease.
这只浣熊的表现方式是普通浣熊绝不会有的，就像被附身了一样。从某种意义上说，确实如此。它患有狂犬病，这种疾病连研究它的科学家都称之为魔鬼般的疾病。这是一种攻击大脑攻击中枢的病毒。它关闭了动物所有的自然抑制力，包括恐惧和痛苦。与此同时，它让动物体内充满肾上腺素，使它们变得更强壮、更执着。原本胆小、容易被吓跑的动物变成了不知疲倦、凶猛的怪物。它们变成了一种仅仅为了传播病毒的载体，攻击任何移动的东西以传播疾病。
Which meant for Michelle, she couldn't just try and fling the raccoon away because it would come after her again. She couldn't outrun it. Any trees she could climb, the raccoon could climb faster. Then Michelle remembered that although she usually didn't bring her cell phone with her on walks, that day, she actually had. The question was how to get it out of her pocket. She needed both hands to hold the raccoon down. She was wearing big mittens. But eventually, after many attempts, she was able to get the phone out and toss it in the snow. Using the speaker phone, she called her house. She got her grown son, Alex.
这意味着对米歇尔来说，她不能只是试着把浣熊甩开，因为它会再次追上来。她跑不过它。任何她能爬上的树，浣熊爬得更快。然后米歇尔想起，虽然她平时散步时不带手机，但那天她居然带了。问题是如何把它从口袋里拿出来。她需要双手按住浣熊。她戴着大手套。但最终，经过多次尝试，她成功拿出手机，扔在雪地里。她用免提拨通了家里的电话。她联系到了成年的儿子亚历克斯。
And I was screaming. I was screaming at the top of my lungs. And he acted like it was like a joke, and it was because the microphone on the phone was being pinned, where it had this sort of strange noise. And I thought to myself-- because it sounded like he was about to hang up, like it was someone doing a prank. And in my head, I said, you have to calm down. I said, Alex. I said, I've been attacked on the driveway by a raccoon.
我当时在尖叫。我声嘶力竭地尖叫。他表现得好像这是个玩笑，那是因为手机上的麦克风被压住了，发出了那种奇怪的噪音。我心想——因为听起来他好像要挂断电话，以为是有人在恶作剧。我在心里对自己说，你必须冷静下来。我说，亚历克斯。我说，我在车道上被一只浣熊攻击了。
Within five minutes, her husband, her son, Alex, and his girlfriend were there. Her son grabbed a big fallen branch and laid it across the raccoon's back. He stood on one end. Michelle stood on the other.
不到五分钟，她的丈夫、儿子亚历克斯和他的女友就赶到了。她儿子抓起一根掉落的大树枝，横在浣熊背上。他站在一头。米歇尔站在另一头。
The two of us are now holding this raccoon, which is still hissing and snarling and clawing. And my husband, he says, I'm going to get a tire iron out of the car and try hitting it and to kill it. So he goes and gets this tire iron out of the car. And he starts to hit it, and he figures he'll hit it once or twice and he'll kill it. Well, he starts hitting it, and he probably hit it between 15 and 20 times. And it's still snarling and clawing.
我们俩现在按住这只浣熊，它还在嘶嘶作响、咆哮、抓挠。我丈夫说，我要从车里拿个轮胎扳手，试着把它打死。于是他去车里拿了轮胎扳手。他开始打它，他想打一两下就能把它打死。好吧，他开始打它，可能打了15到20下。它还在咆哮和抓挠。
So then I said to my son's girlfriend, Olga, I said, Olga. I said, go to the house, and get a knife. And in the meantime, my son takes the tire iron, and my son starts beating on the raccoon. So for at least five minutes, they're taking turns beating this raccoon. And about at the point where Olga is coming back and gets out of the car with these two big knives, the raccoon had died.
于是我对儿子的女友奥尔加说，奥尔加，去屋里拿把刀。与此同时，我儿子拿着轮胎扳手开始猛打那只浣熊。所以至少五分钟里，他们轮流殴打这只浣熊。就在奥尔加回来，手里拿着两把大刀从车上下来的时候，浣熊已经死了。
What Michelle didn't know at the time was that her encounter was not an isolated incident. There's a rabies epidemic in New York, which started in the '90s. In 1989, there were only 55 rabid animal cases in the entire state. By 1993, the number had reached almost 3,000. In 2004, a rabid otter swam up and attacked a six-year-old at a public beach. The child came out of the water with the otter clinging by its teeth to his arm. And one woman I spoke to told me that a rabid raccoon latched itself onto her leg in the middle of the day on her suburban street when she was getting out of her car after a trip to Bed, Bath and Beyond. She said the police had to shoot the raccoon five times before it finally died.
米歇尔当时并不知道，她的遭遇并非个案。纽约正处于狂犬病流行期，始于90年代。1989年，整个州只有55例狂犬病动物病例。到1993年，这一数字已接近3000例。2004年，一只患狂犬病的水獭游上岸，在公共海滩攻击了一名六岁儿童。孩子从水里出来时，水獭还用牙齿紧紧咬着他的胳膊。我采访过的一位女士告诉我，她在大白天开车去 Bed, Bath and Beyond 购物，刚下车，一只患狂犬病的浣熊就跳上她的腿咬住了她。她说警察开了五枪才终于把浣熊打死。
Rabies is almost 100% fatal in humans if the vaccine isn't administered right after exposure. And the '90s brought the first human deaths from rabies in the state in half a century. There have been three to date. Two of them were children bitten by rabid bats in their sleep. Which brings me to a quick public service announcement. A bat can bite you in your sleep without you even knowing it and without leaving a mark. So if you find one in a room with the sleeping person, you have to catch it and have it tested. And if you can't catch it, you should go to a doctor. I'm serious. I learned about this, it freaked me out, and now I want to tell people.
如果暴露后不立即接种疫苗，人类患狂犬病的死亡率几乎是100%。90年代，该州半个世纪以来首次出现因狂犬病导致的死亡案例。迄今已有三例。其中两名是儿童，在睡梦中被患狂犬病的蝙蝠咬伤。这让我想到了一个简短的公共服务公告。蝙蝠可以在你睡梦中咬你，你甚至察觉不到，也不会留下痕迹。所以如果你发现蝙蝠和睡觉的人在同一个房间，你必须把它抓起来并送检。如果你抓不到，你应该去看医生。我是认真的。我了解到这一点时，被吓坏了，现在我想告诉大家。
For Michelle, of course, there was no doubt of exposure. She had two fang marks on her leg, raccoon blood all over her clothes, and a battered raccoon carcass in a plastic bag. But getting treatment proved to be its own type of horror story. First, she called the vet, who told her to call the Health Department. She called the Health Department, but they were closed on weekends, so she left a message and called another Health Department in a different county. Same thing. Eventually, she just went to the emergency room on her own, where she was told that this wasn't an emergency. She had 10 to 14 days before she needed to get a shot, and she should just call the Health Department again after the weekend.
对米歇尔来说，当然毫无疑问是暴露了。她的腿上有两个牙印，衣服上沾满了浣熊的血，塑料袋里装着一只被打得面目全非的浣熊尸体。但接受治疗的过程却成了她自己的恐怖故事。首先，她打电话给兽医，兽医让她打给卫生部门。她打电话给卫生部门，但周末关门了，所以她留了言，又打给另一个县的卫生部门。情况一样。最后，她只能自己去了急诊室，却被告知这不是紧急情况。她在需要接种疫苗前有10到14天的时间，周末过后应该再给卫生部门打个电话。
Early Monday morning, the guy from the Health Department where she left her first message on Saturday called her back. She told them everything was fine. She'd been to the hospital.
周一一大早，她在周六留言的那个卫生部门的工作人员回了电话。她告诉他们一切都好，她已经去过医院了。
And I said, well, I was told I had 10 to 14 days. And he says, you don't have 10 to 14 days. You have 72 hours from the moment that you are bitten. He says, you must have a shot by the end of today.
我说，嗯，我被告知我有10到14天的时间。他说，你没有10到14天。你从被咬的那一刻起只有72小时。他说，你今天结束前必须打针。
The man on the phone wasn't in Michelle's county, so he told her to go to her own Health Department, and they would give her the shot. But when she called there, they said they needed to test the carcass for rabies first, which meant sending it to the rabies laboratory two hours away in Albany. Michelle begged them to just give her the shot first and worry about Albany later, so they made arrangements for her to go to the closest hospital in yet another county.
电话那头的人不在米歇尔所在的县，所以他让她去她自己的卫生部门，他们会给她打针。但当她打电话过去时，他们说需要先检测尸体是否有狂犬病，这意味着要送到两个小时车程外的奥尔巴尼狂犬病实验室。米歇尔恳求他们先给她打针，再去管奥尔巴尼的事，于是他们安排她去另一个县最近的医院。
So my husband and I go. And of course, we have to wait time in the emergency room, and then we get in. And then when we're inside, then someone comes and tells me that I live in Putnam County and I'm in a hospital in Westchester, and that they can't give me the shots.
我和我丈夫去了。当然，我们不得不等在急诊室，然后进去了。进门后，有人告诉我，我住在普特南县，我现在在威彻斯特的医院，他们不能给我打针。
Oh my god.
天哪。
So I am so distraught at this point. And I start crying.
我当时非常崩溃。我开始哭。
The first time during this whole episode, I should point out, that you actually cried, right?
我应该指出，这是你在这整件事中第一次真正哭出来，对吧？
Yes, this was. This was the first time that I cried. I was-- you know. I--
是的，就是这次。这是我第一次哭。我当时……你知道。我……
You survived the attack by the raccoon. You survived hitting it over the head with a tire iron 50 times. And then the thing that finally brought you to your knees was the US health care system.
你在浣熊的攻击中幸存了下来，你在用轮胎扳手打了它50下后幸存了下来。然后最终让你跪地求饶的是美国医疗系统。
Yes, that's exactly right. So I started to cry. And I just said, isn't there-- I said, what's the problem? And then I'm starting to learn that rabies immunoglobulin is a very expensive shot. And the retail price of it was something like $3,200 or $3,500.
是的，没错。所以我开始哭。我说，难道就没有……我说，有什么问题吗？然后我开始了解到，狂犬病免疫球蛋白是一种非常昂贵的针剂。零售价大约是3200或3500美元。
Finally, they gave her the shot, but they gave it to her in the wrong place-- the buttocks, and not in her arm like they were supposed to. And then she needed five follow-up shots, but she couldn't find a doctor to give her any. She called eight doctors, and none of them would even see her until she threatened to call the State Board of Health. Eventually, she got the shots, and today, everything is fine, except Michelle doesn't see her home in the woods the way she once did-- as a peaceful refuge.
最后，他们给她打了针，但打错了位置——打在臀部，而不是本该打的手臂上。然后她需要后续注射五针，但她找不到医生给她打。她打了八个医生的电话，在威胁说要给州卫生委员会打电话之前，没有一个人愿意看她。最终，她打完了针，今天一切都很好，只是米歇尔不再像以前那样看待她树林里的家——把它看作是一个宁静的避风港。
I mean, I felt so betrayed by nature. That's actually how I felt. I felt that nature betrayed me. Because I would take walks every day in the woods, and I had never felt threatened. And I remember waking up the next day and thinking that all of the hills around me, that there were raccoons standing on all these hills, waiting until I got out the door, and they were going to come running toward-- it was like the army waiting for its victim to come. And I had this image that these raccoons were just all going to come down from the hills. And if I ever go to walk and I don't have the cell phone, I will always feel a little fear.
我是说，我感觉被大自然背叛了。事实上我就是这样感觉的。我觉得大自然背叛了我。因为我每天都在树林里散步，从来没感到被威胁。我还记得第二天醒来时想，我周围所有的山上，山上都站着浣熊，等着我出门，它们会朝我跑过来——就像军队在等待受害者一样。我想象着这些浣熊都会从山上冲下来。如果我以后散步没带手机，我总会感到一丝恐惧。
Years before her attack, Michelle went on safari in South Africa. She saw lions and giraffes and rhinos. Coming up her drive at night, after she got home from the trip, she peered into the woods around her house and imagined that there were wild animals out there, like there had been on safari. Now she says she doesn't wonder about it anymore. She knows for a fact there are wild animals out there, and it's not a comforting thought.
在她遇袭前几年，米歇尔去南非参加过游猎之旅。她看到了狮子、长颈鹿和犀牛。从那次旅行回来后，晚上开车回车道时，她注视着房子周围的树林，想象着像游猎时一样外面有野生动物。现在她说她不再怀疑了。她确切地知道外面有野生动物，这并不是一个让人心安的想法。
Alex Blumberg, these days, he's a podcast impresario and the host of the podcast, Without Fail.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格，如今他是一位播客大亨，也是播客《Without Fail》的主持人。
[MUSIC - "EVIL" BY 45 GRAVE"]
[音乐 - 45 Grave乐队的《Evil》]
Act Two, The Hitcher. OK, I believe that we have all learned an important lesson about rabies and bats and raccoons, not to mention a lesson about carbon monoxide. And so to introduce this next story, I don't think there's much more I need to say right now than hitchhiking is dangerous or can be dangerous. It can be bad. And if you don't believe me, Bill Eville tells this true story of what happened to him and his brother.
第二幕，《搭车客》。好吧，我相信我们都学到了关于狂犬病、蝙蝠和浣熊的重要一课，更不用说关于一氧化碳的一课了。为了引出下一个故事，我想现在我没什么比说“搭便车很危险，或者说可能很危险”更重要的了。这可能会很糟糕。如果你不相信我，比尔·埃维尔讲述了他和他兄弟身上发生的这个真实故事。
When I was 12 and my older brother, Jim, 14, our parents dropped us off at one of those agricultural fairs, the kind with the big Ferris wheel, blue ribbon pigs, and hot dog eating contests. This was on Martha's Vineyard and usually our parents went with us. But Jim and I were getting older. He was a teenager now, and we wanted to do it alone. There were girls to impress.
我12岁那年，14岁的哥哥吉姆和我在某个农业集市被父母放下，那种有大摩天轮、蓝带猪和吃热狗比赛的集市。那是在马萨葡萄园岛，通常父母会陪着我们。但吉姆和我都长大了。他现在是个少年了，我们想独自行动。还有女孩要给她们留下印象呢。
We were told to call home for a ride when we were ready. But at the end of the night, we decided it would be cooler to hitchhike. We weren't scared. This was 1977 and Martha's Vineyard still a relatively sleepy island. Everyone hitchhiked there. It didn't take us long to get a ride, some guy heading to Edgartown to meet his friends. We lived in Oak Bluffs-- out of his way-- but he said he could take us halfway home. Jim and I didn't even think about saying no. We were too excited for the adventure to begin.
我们被告知准备好后打电话给家里来接。但在夜深时，我们决定搭便车更酷。我们并不害怕。那是1977年，马萨葡萄园岛还是一个相对安静的岛屿。每个人都在那里搭便车。没花多久我们就搭上了一辆车，一个人正要去埃德加敦见朋友。我们住在橡树崖——离他的方向很远——但他说是可以送我们走一半的路。吉姆和我甚至都没想过拒绝。我们太兴奋了，冒险才刚刚开始。
True to his word, the guy dropped us off halfway home. This was out by the big bridge along the beach road. During the day, this spot is filled with people jumping off the railing into the water, but at night, no one goes there. No swimmers, or fishermen, or even kids looking to get high. Jim and I stood by the side of the road, listening to the ocean pound the sand and the wind blow through the dunes. We peered into the darkness, hoping to see headlights. But there was nothing, just the moon and some stars and a gnawing feeling we had made a big mistake.
那人很守信用，把我们放在了一半路程的地方。那是在海滩公路上的大桥旁。白天，这里挤满了从栏杆上跳进水里的人，但晚上没人会去那里。没有游泳者，没有渔夫，甚至没有想来这里买毒品的孩子。吉姆和我站在路边，听着海浪拍打沙滩，风吹过沙丘。我们向黑暗中望去，希望能看到车灯。但什么也没有，只有月亮和星星，还有一种我们犯了大错的烦躁感。
After about 20 minutes of standing around, we finally saw a car approaching. "Get in front," Jim said, "And try to look small and pathetic." This wasn't hard to do. The car flew by us, kicking up sand, which stung my legs. "Crap!" I yelled. But then the tires locked up, and the car fishtailed. It skidded to a stop about 100 yards away. We ran to the car. It was a big white cruiser with four doors.
站了大约20分钟后，我们终于看到一辆车驶来。“站到前面去，”吉姆说，“尽量看起来小一点、可怜一点。”这并不难做到。车飞驰而过，扬起的沙子刺痛了我的双腿。“该死！”我大喊。但随后轮胎锁死了，车身在路上滑行。它在100码外摇摆着停了下来。我们跑向那辆车。那是一辆四门的白色大巡洋舰。
I yanked open the back door, jumped in, and slid on my butt to the far window. There were three people up front. The driver was hunched over the wheel and wore his hair in a thick afro. A woman sat in the middle. She had straight blond hair with a crooked part running down the center. Another guy, so tall his head almost touched the roof of the car, rode shotgun .
我猛地拉开后门，跳了进去，屁股滑到了靠窗那一侧。前座有三个人。司机弓着背，留着浓密的非洲发型。一个女人坐在中间，留着直直的金发，中间有一道歪歪斜斜的缝。另一个人太高了，头几乎顶到了车顶，坐在副驾驶位置。
"Thanks for stopping," I said. "We're headed to Oak Bluffs." No one said a word. I turned to the open door where Jim still stood. "Come on," I said. "Get in." Jim hesitated. He looked into the car and shook his head back and forth. Then the driver began revving the engine. I saw my brother take a deep breath. Then he climbed in and joined me. His door barely closed when the car took off. We moved fast, swerving in and out of our lane. No one talked the entire ride.
“谢谢你们停车，”我说，“我们要去橡树崖。”没人说话。我转向吉姆依然站着的开口处。“快点，”我说，“上车。”吉姆犹豫了一下。他往车里看了一眼，摇了摇头。然后司机开始猛踩油门。我看到哥哥深吸了一口气。接着他也爬了上来，坐到我身边。他的门刚关上，车就冲了出去。我们开得很快，在车道上歪歪斜斜地穿梭。整个行程没人说话。
By the time we reached Oak Bluffs, I decided I didn't want these people to know where we lived. "Right here will be fine," I said, just past Waban Park, down near where the Sea View Hotel used to be. The car didn't slow down. Thinking the driver didn't hear me, I tried again. "We'd like to be let out now," I said. We drove by Ocean Park, the flying horses carousel, and then the harbor with all the boats tucked in for the night in their berths. The whole time, I kept asking to be let out, trying to make it sound like each spot I pointed to was the one we really preferred. But there was no reaction. We just kept moving.
当我们到达橡树崖时，我决定不想让这些人知道我们住哪儿。“就在这儿下就行，”我说道，刚过了沃班公园，在老海景酒店曾经所在的地方附近。车没有减速。我以为司机没听见，又试了一次。“我们要下车了，”我说。我们经过了海洋公园、旋转木马，然后是港口，所有的船都泊在锚位里过夜。整个过程中，我一直在要求下车，尽量让每个我指的地方听起来都是我们真正想去的地方。但没有反应。我们一直在前进。
Eventually, we passed the last house along the Methodist campground, where the Sunday before, I had climbed the stage at the old tabernacle and sang with my cousins before a crowd of hundreds, "Raindrops Keep Falling on My Head." We began to climb the hill that led out of town, and I grew silent. Jim took up where I left off. Recently, his voice had changed and he had a new, deep baritone. When his voice cracked, making him sound like a little kid again, he stopped talking, too.
最终，我们经过了卫理公会营地边的最后一栋房子，上周日我曾爬上老帐幕的舞台，和表兄弟们在数百人面前演唱了《雨点不断落在我的头上》。我们开始爬出镇子的山坡，我沉默了。吉姆接着我的话说。最近他的声音变了，有了一种新的、深沉的男中音。当他的声音因变声而听起来又像个小孩子时，他也停止了说话。
I tried to convince myself it was just a joke-- scare the crap out of some kids on a boring Saturday night. And I almost believed this. But then, about 15 minutes outside of town, we took a left turn to a graveyard. Jim and I knew this graveyard. We had relatives buried there, old whaling captains who helped settle the island back in the 1600s. We came up here sometimes with our grandfather to pay our respects. It was a heavily wooded place with trails that twisted deep into the forest. During the day, it was fun to run along these trails, jumping out from behind a rock or bush to scare each other. We had never been up here at night, though.
我试着说服自己这只是个玩笑——在一个无聊的周六晚上吓唬几个孩子。我几乎相信了这一点。但大约在离镇子15分钟远的地方，我们左转进了一个墓地。吉姆和我认识这个墓地。我们有亲戚埋在那里，是17世纪帮助定居该岛的老捕鲸船长。我们有时会和爷爷一起来这里祭拜。这是一个树木茂盛的地方，小路深深地蜿蜒进森林。白天在这些小路上跑来跑去，躲在岩石或灌木丛后面吓唬彼此很有趣。但我们从未在晚上来过这里。
I grabbed my brother's hand and pulled myself into his lap. Jim hugged me tight and rested his cheek against mine. He had recently started shaving, and I could feel the hint of razor stubble. This helped calm me down. Jim was the older brother. He would know what to do.
我抓住哥哥的手，把自己拉到他的膝盖上。吉姆紧紧抱住我，脸颊贴着我的脸颊。他最近开始刮胡子，我能感觉到细微的胡渣。这让我平静了下来。吉姆是哥哥。他知道该怎么办。
The car swerved and began circling a large Jesus statue near the front of the graveyard. I was thrown from Jim's lap and landed in the opposite foot well. I scrambled back up as fast as I could. But before I could reach my brother's lap again, Jim opened his door and jumped out of the car.
车身摇晃，开始绕着墓地前的一座耶稣雕像转圈。我被从吉姆膝盖上甩了下去，掉进了对面的脚踏坑里。我尽可能快地爬回去。但还没来得及回到哥哥膝盖上，吉姆就打开车门跳了出去。
We were still moving fast, and the open door flapped in the wind. I felt a hand on my shoulder and looked up. It was the tall man. His fingers were strong and dug into my collarbone. I ducked back into the seat well and crawled to the door. The man still held me by the shoulder, but I pushed as hard as I could with my legs. When I leapt from the car, he lost his grip. For a moment, I floated in the air. When I hit the ground, I rolled for a long time.
我们车速依然很快，敞开的车门在风中拍打。我感到肩膀上有一只手，抬头一看。是那个高个子男人。他的手指很有力，深深扣进我的锁骨。我缩回座位坑里，爬向车门。那个男人依然抓住我的肩膀，但我用腿拼命推开。当我从车上跳下来时，他松了手。有那么一瞬间，我悬在空中。当我落地时，我滚了很远。
I got up and ran towards the woods. I could see a light in the distance and headed for it. The woods opened up into a small clearing, and there was a house and a party in full swing. Lots of people stood outside, drinking around a keg. As soon as I reached the lawn, I turned around to look for my brother. He was still back in the graveyard, running down one of the dirt roads with the car right behind him. "Jim," I screamed. "Jim, over here." A crowd had formed around me, but I didn't look at them. I just kept screaming my brother's name.
我爬起来向树林跑去。我看到远处有灯光，于是朝那边跑。树林在一片小空地上豁然开朗，有一所房子，派对正在进行。很多人站在外面，围着啤酒桶喝酒。一到草坪，我就转身寻找哥哥。他还留在墓地里，跑在一条土路上，车就在他身后。“吉姆，”我尖叫着，“吉姆，这边。”人群围住了我，但我没看他们。我只是不停地尖叫哥哥的名字。
And then he was there, bursting through the woods and running across the lawn, until a clothesline flattened him. I ran to him, kneeled down, and put my hand on his chest. "You OK?" I asked. "Yeah," he said. "You?" Before I could answer, a tall kid with thick glasses squatted down next to us. "What the hell is going on?" he asked. Jim and I stood up, began telling everyone what had happened. While we were talking, four guys from the party ran off to the graveyard. The car's headlights were still visible, moving through the woods, looking for us.
然后他就在那儿，冲破树林穿过草坪，直到一条晒衣绳把他绊倒。我跑向他，跪下来，把手放在他胸口。“没事吧？”我问。“没事，”他说，“你呢？”还没等我回答，一个戴厚眼镜的高个子男孩蹲在我们身边。“到底怎么回事？”他问。吉姆和我站起来，开始告诉大家发生了什么。我们说话时，派对里的四个人跑向墓地。车的车灯依然可见，在树林里移动，寻找我们。
There was shouting, and then the headlights disappeared. When the guys returned, they said the car took off before they could get the license plate. The tall kid with the glasses walked to the keg, poured two beers into blue plastic cups, and offered them to us. Jim and I chugged them down and asked for more.
传来一阵叫喊声，随后车灯消失了。当那些人回来时，他们说车在他们记下车牌前就逃跑了。那个戴眼镜的高个子男孩走到桶前，倒了两杯啤酒递给我们。吉姆和我一饮而尽，又再要了一杯。
Later, two women gave us a ride home. I refused to sit in the back seat and rode up front with the driver. Her name was Betsy, and she had long brown hair and tanned skin. Her father owned The Flying Horses and I had seen her around town. On the drive home, she rubbed my hair and put her arm around my shoulder.
后来，两个女人开车送我们回家。我拒绝坐在后座，坐在前排和司机一起。她叫贝齐，留着棕色长发，皮肤晒得很黑。她父亲拥有旋转木马，我在镇上见过她。开车回家时，她摸摸我的头发，把手搭在我的肩膀上。
When we reached our house, Betsy walked with us to the front door and stood on the porch while we told our parents what had happened. Mom bent down so her face was level with mine. Dad stood next to Jim. My parents were very young. Mom even got carded sometimes at R rated movies. Dad wore a thick mustache and looked good in a tight white T-shirt. While we were talking, my grandparents, who had already gone to bed, came down the stairs in their bathrobes. "Close the door," Gram said. "You're letting in the mosquitoes." Betsy patted me on the cheek and then walked back to her car.
到达我们家时，贝齐陪我们走到前门，站在门廊上，我们告诉父母发生了什么。妈妈弯下腰，脸对着我的脸。爸爸站在吉姆旁边。我的父母非常年轻。妈妈在看R级电影时甚至还会被要求出示证件。爸爸留着浓密的胡子，穿白色紧身T恤看起来很帅。我们说话时，已经上床睡觉的爷爷奶奶穿着睡袍走下楼。“把门关上，”奶奶说，“蚊子都进来了。”贝齐拍拍我的脸颊，然后走回她的车。
The rest of us went into the living room, where Jim and I told our story once more. "What do you think?" Grandpa asked. "Should we call the police?" For a moment, no one spoke. "It's late," Dad finally said. "I think the boys have had enough for one night." Gram patted my head. "It's over, and everyone's safe," she said. "No need to drag it out." I looked at Mom. She nodded, and so I did the same, not because I agreed, but I didn't disagree either. I was just glad to be home. "Let's go to bed," Dad said. "There's tennis in the morning."
其余人走进客厅，吉姆和我又讲了一遍我们的故事。“你们怎么看？”爷爷问，“我们要报警吗？”有一会儿没人说话。“太晚了，”爸爸最终说，“我觉得孩子们今晚受的惊吓够多了。”奶奶拍拍我的头，“结束了，每个人都很安全，”她说，“没必要再折腾了。”我看向妈妈。她点点头，于是我也照做了，不是因为我同意，但我也没反对。我只是庆幸回到家了。“睡觉去吧，”爸爸说，“明天早上还有网球比赛。”
Mom walked me to my bedroom, an old store room I had cleaned out at the beginning of the summer so I could finally have a room of my own. After she tucked me in, I laid there and tried to think about tennis and Labor Day weekend, just three days away. In a little over a week, I would officially be a seventh grader. But I couldn't concentrate. I kept seeing the people in the front seat of that car. Maybe they had followed Betsy's car home from the graveyard and were waiting outside to get me.
妈妈把我送到卧室，那是一间我夏天刚打扫出来的杂物室，这样我终于能有自己的房间了。她帮我掖好被子后，我躺在那里试图想网球和劳动节周末的事，离那只有三天了。再过一周多，我就会正式成为七年级学生了。但我无法集中精神。我一直看到车前座的那几个人。也许他们跟着贝齐的车从墓地回到了家，正在外面等着抓我。
I rubbed my shoulder where the tall man had grabbed me and got out of bed. I changed out of my pajamas into jeans and my favorite green basketball T-shirt. Then I laid down on the floor and slid underneath my bed. For a moment, I felt safe and hidden, but it didn't last. I got up and walked to Jim's room. But when I got there, I realized I didn't want to go in. I continued down the hall and stood outside my parents' bedroom. I could hear them talking quietly together. I almost knocked on their door. Instead, I turned away and moved on to the front room, where my youngest brother, Ted, slept.
我揉了揉被高个子男人抓住的肩膀，下了床。我换下睡衣，穿上牛仔裤和最喜欢的绿色篮球T恤。然后我躺在地板上，溜进了床底下。有一瞬间，我觉得安全和隐蔽，但这没持续多久。我起来走进吉姆的房间。但到了那里，我意识到我不想进去。我继续走下走廊，站在父母卧室外。我能听到他们低声交谈。我差点敲门。取而代之的是，我转身离开，走到最前面的房间，那里住着我最小的弟弟泰德。
Ted was six years old. He'd been asleep when we came home and so didn't know what had happened. I crawled into bed with him and started crying, really crying, so that I had to stuff a pillow in my mouth to keep the noise in. Ted woke up, but didn't say anything at first. He just patted me on the back. Then he asked me what was wrong. But I couldn't speak. I could only cry and hope he kept patting me. And he did, until I finally fell asleep.
泰德六岁。我们回家时他睡着了，所以不知道发生了什么。我爬进他的被窝开始哭，是真的哭了，我不得不把枕头塞进嘴里以掩盖哭声。泰德醒了，但起初什么也没说。他只是拍拍我的后背。然后他问我怎么了。但我无法开口。我只能哭泣，希望他继续拍着我。他确实这样做了，直到我最终睡着。
Bill Eville in New York. Coming up, David Sedaris sees dead people and other scary stories that are absolutely true in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
比尔·埃维尔，在纽约。稍后，大卫·塞达里斯会见到死者，还有其他绝对真实的恐怖故事，一分钟后，当节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, And the Call was Coming From the Basement. We have scary stories for Halloween, all of them absolutely true. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, And the Call was Coming From the Listeners.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。节目每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《电话是从地下室打来的》。我们有万圣节的恐怖故事，全部都是绝对真实的。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《电话是从听众那里打来的》。
Today's show is a rerun, but back when first did this show, we invited you-- yes, you-- to call a special 800 number that we set up here at our radio show to tell us your true scary stories. Hundreds of people called with all kinds of stories. Here's a selection.
今天的节目是重播，但在第一次做这档节目时，我们邀请了你——是的，就是你——拨打我们在这里为您设置的800专用热线，告诉我们你的真实恐怖故事。成百上千的人打来电话讲述各种各样的故事。这里选播一部分。
My name is Erica Parks. This is from when I was, I guess, 18. I worked at a dollhouse supply store, so I was already sort of in a creepy environment. There was little doll heads and hair and eyeballs. I'd come home after closing up the shop at about 10:00 at night. And I didn't have my own car at the time, so I would either get a ride from my parents, or my dad would let me use his Tracker and I would drive myself home.
我叫艾丽卡·帕克斯。这是我大概18岁时的事。我在一家玩偶屋用品店工作，所以我已经身处一种阴森的环境里。那里有小玩偶的头、头发和眼珠。我晚上10点左右关店回家。当时我没有自己的车，所以要么坐父母的车，要么我爸会把他的Tracker让我开回家。
So I was driving myself home this night. And since I was driving my dad's Tracker, I would have expected him to be home. And I pulled into the house, and all the lights were out. And I don't know if you've ever had the feeling where you know someone's watching you, I guess, or-- even though all the signs are that no one's home, you can feel that there's someone present.
那天晚上我开自己的车回家。因为我开的是我爸的车，我本以为他在家。我把车开进院子，所有的灯都关着。我不知道你有没有那种感觉，就是你知道有人在看着你，或者——尽管所有的迹象都表明家里没人，你却能感觉到有人在。
So I parked in front of the house. I walked up the front steps and let myself in. It was completely black. I remember whispering, "Hello? Is there anybody home?" And all of a sudden, in the stairwell, the shape of a man and what I saw later was a baseball bat-- but it could have been anything to me at the time-- reared up out of the dark stairwell. And that's when I knew I was dead, murdered, mutilated, something horrible. And dropped to the ground-- apparently without even a yelp of protest, pretty much just a whimper-- into fetal position.
我把车停在房子前面。走上台阶让自己进去。里面一片漆黑。我记得我小声说：“你好？有人在家吗？”突然，在楼梯间里，一个男人的身影和他手里拿的东西——我后来看到是棒球棍，但当时对我来说可能是任何东西——从黑暗的楼梯间里猛然站起。那一刻我就知道我死定了，被谋杀、肢解，什么恐怖的事情都会发生。倒在地上——显然连一声抗议都没有，基本只有一声呜咽——缩成胎儿姿势。
And I heard laughing, and the light turned on. It was my dad. This is his idea of a joke. And then later, he claimed that it was a character building test and that now I knew myself better. I knew that I needed to be prepared for being mugged or attacked in the dark because I didn't even try to defend myself. But that moment when my dad reared it on the stairs-- and it could have been just about anybody-- was one of the scariest moments of my life.
然后我听到笑声，灯亮了。是我爸。这是他恶作剧的想法。后来，他声称这是一个考验角色塑造的测试，现在我更了解自己了。我知道我需要为在黑暗中被抢劫或攻击做好准备，因为我当时甚至没尝试防御。但我爸在楼梯上猛然站起的那一刻——可能任何人都会——那是我生命中最恐怖的时刻之一。
: Hi, my name is Amy Mackinnon. I was about 2 and 1/2, and it was told around my little neighborhood that a monster had escaped from the local insane asylum. That's what my parents told my brothers and me and our friends' parents told them. And the monster was tall, and green, and really quiet, and ferocious. So they had to cancel Halloween. And we were, of course, devastated, but my parents said, well, because Halloween is canceled, we'll have a party in the basement, in our basement. We'll have all of the friends over from the neighborhood because it would just be too dangerous to be out in the dark with a monster on the loose.
：你好，我叫艾米·麦金农。我当时大约2岁半，我家附近都在传一个怪物从当地的精神病院逃出来了。我父母就是这么告诉我和哥哥们的，我们朋友的父母也这么告诉他们。那个怪物很高，绿色的，非常安静，而且很凶猛。所以他们不得不取消了万圣节。我们当然很崩溃，但我父母说，好吧，因为万圣节取消了，我们在地下室办个派对，在我们地下室。我们会把附近所有的朋友都叫来，因为在黑暗中带着一个流窜的怪物实在太危险了。
So my mother decorated our basement. She did a fantastic job. The best part I remember were the donuts that were hanging from a clothesline. So the party is going really well. All of the kids are there. There are a few mothers there. The music's playing. And all of a sudden, we heard a boom from upstairs. And one mother said, shh, shh. And the music stopped. And my mother was near me. And then we heard boom, boom. And it was dead silence in the basement.
所以我妈妈装饰了我们的地下室。她做得棒极了。我记得最棒的部分是挂在晒衣绳上的甜甜圈。派对进行得很顺利。所有的孩子都在。有几位妈妈也在。音乐响着。突然，我们听到楼上传来一声巨响。一位妈妈说，嘘，嘘。音乐停了。我妈妈就在我身边。然后我们听到砰，砰。地下室里一片死寂。
And a mother said, "What was that?" And another mother said, "I think it's the monster."
一位妈妈说：“那是什么？”另一位妈妈说：“我想那是怪物。”
And all of a sudden, we heard the basement door creaking open. And then I saw this enormous black boot on the first step. Boom. And then the next. Boom. Very slowly, I could see the boots, the legs, the enormous chest, and sticking straight out, two arms. And the monster came down the stairs so slowly with this green face. Its black suit was too short for it. It had bolts coming out of either side of its neck.
突然，我们听到地下室的门吱呀一声开了。然后我看到第一级台阶上有一只巨大的黑靴子。砰。接着是下一级。砰。非常缓慢地，我能看到靴子、腿、巨大的胸膛，还有直直伸出的两条胳膊。怪物非常缓慢地走下楼梯，脸是绿色的。它的西装太短了。脖子两侧伸出螺栓。
Once the arms were visible, chaos in the basement. Kids screaming, running everywhere. My mother was next to me. I, not quite three, grabbed hold of her thigh, and I can remember digging my fingers into her leg, trying desperately to claw onto something, screaming. And I wet my pants.
当胳膊清晰可见时，地下室里一片混乱。孩子们尖叫着，到处乱跑。我妈妈就在我身边。还没满三岁的我抓住了她的大腿，我记得手指深陷进她腿里，绝望地想抓住什么，尖叫着。我还尿裤子了。
And I can remember seeing my older brother Scott race for a toy chest that was under the stairs. And I can see his eyes, meeting his eyes as he slowly lowered the lid. And I was so angry that I wasn't with him. I can remember my other brothers, Rob and Michael, leaping for the basement window. And there must have been something under it that helped them propel them out the window. They jumped out the window with a friend. They ran down the street to a phone booth, somehow had a quarter, and called the police.
我记得看到我大哥哥斯科特跑向楼梯下的玩具箱。我能看到他的眼睛，当他慢慢放下盖子时，我看到了他的眼神。我当时很生气自己没和他在一起。我记得我的其他哥哥，罗伯和迈克尔，跳向地下室的窗口。下面肯定有什么东西帮他们跳了出去。他们和一个朋友跳出了窗户。他们跑向街上的电话亭，不知怎么有了硬币，报了警。
Meanwhile, the kids are screaming, and screaming, and screaming everywhere. And the monster is bewildered. He's looking around. His arms are still outstretched. He's not saying anything. He's not grabbing for anyone. And I'm still screaming. My ears hurt because I'm screaming so loudly. And then the monster looked at me, and he said, "It's OK, Amy. It's OK. It's OK." But I couldn't hear him anymore.
同时，孩子们到处在尖叫，不停地尖叫。怪物感到很困惑。它环顾四周。它的胳膊依然伸着。它什么也没说。它没有抓住任何人。我还一直在尖叫。因为我尖叫得太大声，耳朵都疼了。然后怪物看着我，说：“没事的，艾米。没事的。没事的。”但我已经听不见了。
The next thing I remember is being in a little makeshift bed in my parents' kitchen. And my mother was there. And later, after my father had showered, I can remember him walking to the kitchen. I turned my head and could see his feet. And then he crouched down to talk to me. He said, "Amy--" But before he could get another word out, I threw up on his shoes.
我记得的下一件事是躺在父母厨房的一张简易床上。妈妈在那里。后来，爸爸洗完澡后，我记得他走进厨房。我转过头能看到他的脚。然后他蹲下来和我说话。他说，“艾米——”但还没等他说出下一个词，我就吐在了他的鞋上。
Hi. This is Jesse Vorhees. I don't know if this is the kind of scary story you're looking for, but it's the scariest thing that's probably ever happened in my life. My mom had surgery for bladder cancer and got her bladder removed. And I spent the night in the hospital with her the night after her surgery. And I guess when you're ventilated for long enough artificially, your body sort of forgets to breathe for itself.
你好。我是杰西·沃希斯。我不知道这是不是你想要的那种恐怖故事，但这可能是我生命中发生过的最恐怖的事情。我妈妈做了膀胱癌手术，切除了膀胱。手术后的那晚，我在医院陪她。我想当你被人工通气足够久后，身体就会忘记如何自主呼吸。
And so after she came out of her surgery, it took a number of hours. She was sort of breathing in these ragged gasps. And sometimes it would take her a long time before she took her next breath. And so my job was sort of to make sure that she didn't-- or at least the job I gave myself was to make sure there wasn't too long between her breaths. And so I would nudge her or wake her up a little bit if it took too long.
所以她手术出来后，过了好几个小时。她呼吸时气喘吁吁。有时在下一次呼吸前要隔很久。所以我的工作就是确保她不会——或者说我交给自己的任务是确保她呼吸间隙不会太长。所以如果时间太长，我就推推她或者把她弄醒一点。
And so I was beside her in her hospital room while she was sleeping. And I was trying to stay awake. And I think she went in around midnight, and around probably 2:00 in the morning or so, I think I fell asleep. So around 4:00 in the morning, I heard the nurse starting to open up the door. And I suddenly realized I had fallen asleep. And so I listened in the dark for her next breath, and I didn't hear it. And I became convinced that she wasn't going to breathe again and that just because I had fallen asleep, she was gone.
所以当她睡觉时，我陪在她病房里。我试图保持清醒。我想她是午夜左右进来的，大概凌晨2点左右，我睡着了。所以凌晨4点左右，我听到护士开始打开门。我突然意识到自己睡着了。所以我屏住呼吸在黑暗中听她的下一次呼吸，但没听到。我认定她再也不会呼吸了，仅仅因为我睡着了，她就没了。
I think it's actually probably the most scared I've ever been in my life. And I think what was so scary about it was that there was just no way of getting it back, that something stupid like falling asleep, and there was nothing I was ever going to be able to do to change it. And then a couple of seconds later, I heard her breathe again. And then it was all over. And it's strange because nobody knew what had gone on but me. Nobody really knew that anything scary had happened but me. Whew. That's my story.
我想这可能是我一生中最害怕的一次。我想最可怕的是，没法挽回了，那种蠢事，比如睡着了，而且无论我做什么都无法改变了。几秒钟后，我听到了她再次呼吸。然后一切都过去了。奇怪的是，除了我没人知道发生了什么。没人真的知道发生了什么恐怖的事情。呼。这就是我的故事。
Thanks to everybody who called our special scary stories hotline. If you're keeping track, the scary things that we have learned so far today that we must avoid at all costs are these. Number one, carbon monoxide. Number two, rabid animals. Number three, hitchhiking. Number four, your own parents.
感谢所有拨打我们恐怖故事热线的人。如果你在记录，我们今天学到的必须不惜一切代价避免的恐怖事情有这些。第一，一氧化碳。第二，患狂犬病的动物。第三，搭便车。第四，你自己的父母。
This actually brings us to Act Four, where we're going to learn a few more things to avoid. Act Four, Graveyard Shift. The ghosts and skeletons and monsters who rise from the grave on Halloween are a kind of fake children's story version of death. But one Halloween a couple of years ago, David Sedaris decided that he was going to go for the real thing on Halloween. He was going for the real thing, the medical examiner's office-- the morgue, basically-- the morgue, a place filled with actual dead people. He read his account of what happened there in front of a live audience at the Orpheum Theater in Minneapolis.
这实际上带我们到了第四幕，我们将学习更多要避免的事情。第四幕，《墓地轮班》。万圣节从坟墓中爬出来的鬼魂、骷髅和怪物，是关于死亡的一种虚假的儿童版故事。但几年前的一个万圣节，大卫·塞达里斯决定在万圣节去见识真正的死亡。他要接触真实的东西，医学检验办公室——基本上就是停尸房——停尸房，一个满是真实死人的地方。他在明尼阿波利斯的奥菲姆剧院现场朗读了他在此处的经历。
The thing about dead people is that they look really dead-- fake almost, like models made of wax. This I learned at a medical examiner's office I visited in the fall of 1997. While the bodies seemed unreal, the tools used to pick them apart were disturbingly familiar. It might be different in places with better funding, but here, they used hedge clippers to snip through rib cages. Chest cavities were emptied of blood with cheap metal soup ladles, the kind they use in cafeterias. And the autopsy tables were lubricated with whatever dish detergent happened to be on sale.
死人的事就是，他们看起来真的很死——几乎是假的，像蜡做的模型。这是我在1997年秋天参观医学检验办公室时学到的。虽然身体看起来不真实，但用来拆解它们的工具却令人不安地熟悉。在资金充裕的地方可能有所不同，但在这里，他们用树篱剪来剪断胸腔。胸腔用廉价的金属汤勺清空血迹，就是食堂用的那种。解剖台则用碰巧打折的洗洁精润滑。
Also familiar were the songs-- oldies, mainly, that issued from the blood spattered clock radio and formed a kind of soundtrack. When I was young, I associated Three Dog Night with my seventh grade shop teacher, who proudly identified himself as the group's biggest fan. Now, though, whenever I hear "Joy to the World," I think of a fibroid tumor positioned upon a Styrofoam plate. Funny how that happens.
同样熟悉的是歌曲——主要是老歌，从溅满血迹的时钟收音机里传出来，形成了一种配乐。我年轻时，把三狗之夜乐队和我的七年级手工老师联系在一起，他自豪地自称是该乐队的头号粉丝。但现在，每当听到《欢乐颂》，我就会想到放在聚苯乙烯泡沫塑料盘子上的纤维瘤。有趣的是，事情总是这样。
While at the medical examiner's office, I dressed in a protective suit, complete with a bonnet and a pair of Tyvek booties. Citizens were disemboweled, one right after another. And on the surface, I'm sure I seemed fine with it. Then at night, I'd return to my hotel, double lock the door, and stand under the shower until all the soap and shampoo was used up. The people in the next room must have wondered what was going on. An hour of running water and then this blubbery voice-- "I do believe in spooks. I do believe in spooks. I do, I do, I do, I do, I do."
在医学检验办公室期间，我穿着防护服，戴着帽子和一双泰vek鞋套。市民们一个接一个地被剖开。从表面上看，我肯定对此表现得很自然。然后晚上回到旅馆，双重锁好门，站在淋浴下，直到所有的香皂和洗发水用完。隔壁的人一定在想怎么回事。一个小时的流水声，然后这个充满气泡的声音——“我相信鬼魂。我相信鬼魂。我信，我信，我信，我信，我信。”
It's not like I'd walked into this completely unprepared. Even as a child, I was fascinated by death, not in a spiritual sense, but an aesthetic one. A hamster or guinea pig would pass away, and after burying the body, I'd dig it back up, over and over, until all that remained was a shoddy pelt. That earned me a certain reputation, especially when I moved on to other people's pets.
并不是我完全没准备。即使在小时候，我也着迷于死亡，不是精神层面的，而是审美层面的。仓鼠或豚鼠去世后，埋葬尸体后，我会一遍又一遍把它挖出来，直到剩下的只有一块破皮。这为我赢得了某种名声，尤其是在我转向别人的宠物之后。
Igor, they called me. Wicked. Spooky. But I think my interest was actually fairly common, at least amongst adolescent boys. At that age, death is something that happens only to animals and grandparents. And studying it is like a science project-- the good kind that doesn't involve homework. Most kids grow out of it, but the passing of time only heightened my curiosity.
他们叫我伊戈尔。邪恶。阴森。但我认为我的兴趣实际上很普遍，至少在青春期男孩中是这样。在那个年纪，死亡只是动物和祖父母才会发生的事。研究它就像科学项目——不需要做家庭作业的那种好项目。大多数孩子长大了就不会这样了，但时光流逝只会增加我的好奇心。
As a teenager, I saved up my babysitting money and bought a $75 copy of Medicolegal Investigations of Death, a sort of bible for forensic pathologists. It shows what you might look like if you bit an extension cord while standing in a shallow pool of water, if you were crushed by a tractor, struck by lightning, strangled with a spiral or a non-spiral telephone cord, hit with a claw hammer, burned, shot, drowned, stabbed, or feasted upon by wild or domestic animals.
十几岁时，我攒下保姆费，买了本75美元的《死亡医学法律调查》，那是法医的某种圣经。它展示了如果你站在浅水池里咬了延长线，如果你被拖拉机压碎，被雷击，被螺旋或非螺旋电话线勒死，被爪锤击中，被烧伤、枪击、淹死、刺伤，或被野生或家养动物吞食，你看起来会是什么样。
The captions read like really great poem titles, my favorite being, "Extensive Mildew on the Face of a Recluse." I stared at that picture for hours on end, hoping it might inspire me, but I know nothing about poetry. And the best I came up with was pretty lame. Behold the recluse looking pensive. Mildew, though, is quite extensive. On his head, both aft and fore, he maybe should have got out more.
说明文字读起来像非常棒的诗题，我最喜欢的是，“隐居者脸上的大片霉菌”。我盯着那张照片看了几个小时，希望它能启发我，但我对诗歌一窍不通。我能想出的最好的诗也很蹩脚。且看隐士面容忧郁。霉菌确实范围很广。在他头上，无论前后，也许他应该多出门走走。
I know nothing about biology either. The pathologist tried to educate me, but I was too distracted by the grotesque. My discovery, for instance, that if you jumped from a tall building and land on your back, your eyes will pop out of your head and hang by bloody cables. "Like those joke glasses," I said to the chief medical examiner. The man was nothing if not professional. And his response to my observations was always the same. "Well," he'd sigh. "Not really."
我对生物学也一窍不通。病理学家试图教育我，但我太被怪诞的东西分心了。比如，我的发现，如果你从高楼跳下背部着地，眼睛会从眼眶里跳出来，挂在血淋淋的电缆上。“就像那些笑话眼镜，”我对首席法医说。那人极其专业。他对我的观察反应永远是一样的。“嗯，”他会叹气说，“并不是这样。”
After a week in the autopsy suite, I still couldn't open a Denny's menu without wanting to throw up. At night, I'd close my eyes and see the buckets of withered hands stored in the morgue's secondary cooler. They had brains, too, a whole wall of them shelved like preserves in a general store. Then there were the bits and pieces, a forsaken torso, a pretty blond scalp, a pair of eyes floating in a baby food jar. Put them all together, and you had an incredibly bright secretary, who could type like the wind, but never answer the telephone.
在解剖室待了一周后，我依然无法打开丹尼餐厅的菜单而不感到想吐。晚上，我闭上眼睛就会看到储存在停尸房辅助冷却器里的成桶枯萎的手。他们还有大脑，整面墙的大脑像杂货店里的蜜饯一样摆在架子上。还有零碎的东西，被遗弃的躯干，漂亮的金色头皮，飘在婴儿食品罐里的一对眼睛。把它们合在一起，你就有了一位极其聪明的秘书，她打字如飞，却永远不会接电话。
I'd lie awake thinking of things like this, but then my mind would return to the freshly dead, who are most often whole, or at least, whole-ish. Most of them were delivered naked, zipped up in identical body bags. Family members were not allowed inside the building. And so the corpses had no context. Unconnected to the living, they were like these strange creatures, related only to one another.
我躺着醒着思考这些事情，但随后我的心思又会回到新鲜的死者身上，他们大多是完整的，或者至少是完整样的。大多数人被送来时赤身裸体，装在一样的尸袋里。家人不允许进入楼内。所以尸体没有背景。与活人脱节，他们就像这些奇怪的生物，只与彼此有关联。
A police report would explain that Mrs. Daniels had been killed when a truck lost control and drove through the front window of a hamburger stand. She had been a customer waiting in line. In cases like hers, I needed more than a standard report. There had to be a reason this woman was run down, as without one, the same thing might happen to me. Three men are shot to death while attending a child's christening. And you tell yourself, sure, they were hanging out with the wrong crowd. But buying a hamburger-- I buy hamburgers. Or I used to, anyway.
警方报告会解释说丹尼尔斯太太在卡车失控冲进汉堡店前窗时身亡。她当时是排队等待的顾客。在像她这样的案例中，我需要的不仅仅是一份标准报告。这个女人被撞倒一定有原因，否则，同样的事情也可能发生在我身上。三名男子在参加儿童洗礼时被枪杀。你告诉自己，当然，他们是在和错误的人群混在一起。但买汉堡——我买汉堡。或者我过去常买。
This medical examiner's office was in the western United States, in a city where guns are readily available and drivers are known to shoot each other over parking spaces. The building was low-slung and mean looking, set on the far edge of the downtown area, between the railroad tracks and a rubber stamp manufacturer. In the lobby was a potted plant and the receptionist who kept a can of Mountain Glen air freshener in her desk drawer. "For decomps," she explained, meaning those who had died alone and rotted a while before being found.
这个医学检验办公室位于美国西部，在一个枪支唾手可得、司机为了停车位而互相射击的城市。建筑低矮且看起来很凶，座落在市中心边缘，铁路和橡胶印章制造商之间。大堂里有一盆植物，接待员在桌子抽屉里放了一罐山谷空气清新剂。“为了处理腐烂物，”她解释说，意思是那些独自死去并腐烂一段时间才被发现的人。
We had such a case on Halloween-- an elderly man who had tumbled from a ladder while replacing a light bulb. Four and 1/2 days on the floor of his un-air-conditioned home. And as the bag was unzipped, the room filled with what the attending pathologist termed, "the smell of job security." The autopsy took place in the morning and was the best argument for the buddy system I had ever seen. Never live alone, I told myself. Before you change a light bulb, call someone from the other room and have them watch until you're finished.
万圣节我们就有这样一个案子——一位老人在换灯泡时从梯子上摔了下来。在没空调的家中地板上躺了四天半。当尸袋拉开，房间里充斥着主治病理学家所说的“就业保障的臭味”。解剖发生在早上，是我见过的Buddy System（伙伴互助系统）最完美的论证。永远不要独居，我对自己说。在你换灯泡前，把人从隔壁叫来，让他们看着直到你换完。
By this point in my stay, my list of don'ts covered three pages and included such reminders as, never fall asleep in a dumpster, never drive a convertible behind a flatbed truck, never get drunk near a train, never get old.
在我逗留期间，我的“不要做”清单覆盖了三页，包括诸如，永远不要在垃圾桶里睡着，永远不要在平板卡车后面开敞篷车，永远不要在火车附近喝醉，永远不要变老。
I hadn't timed my visit to coincide with Halloween, but that's the way it worked out. You think that most of the casualties would involve trick or treaters hit by cars or done in by tainted candy. But actually, the day was just like any other. In the morning, we had our decomposed senior, and after lunch, I accompanied a female pathologist to a murder trial. She had performed the victim's autopsy and was testifying on behalf of the prosecution.
我的访问并不是为了配合万圣节，但事情就是这样发生的。你以为大多数伤亡会涉及被车撞倒或被有毒糖果毒死的捣蛋鬼。但事实上，这一天和其他日子没什么两样。早上，我们处理了腐烂的长者，午餐后，我陪一位女病理学家去参加谋杀审判。她执行了受害者的尸检，并代表检方作证。
There were plenty of things that should have concerned me-- the blood spatter evidence, the trajectory of the bullets. But all I could concentrate on was the defendant's mother, who'd come to court wearing cutoff jeans and a Ghostbusters T-shirt. It couldn't have been easy for her, but still you had to wonder, what would she consider a dress-up occasion?
有很多事情本该让我担心——血迹飞溅证据，弹道轨迹。但我只能专注于被告的母亲，她穿着剪短的牛仔裤和《捉鬼敢死队》T恤出庭。这对她来说一定不容易，但你还是不禁要问，她认为什么样的场合才算正式打扮？
After the trial, I watched as another female pathologist collected maggots from a spinal column found in the desert. There was a decomposed head, too, and before leaving work, she planned to simmer it and study the exposed cranium for contusions. I was asked to pass this information along to the chief medical examiner. And looking back, I perhaps should have chosen my words more carefully. "Fire up the kettle," I told him. "Old-fashioned skull boil at 5:00 PM."
审判结束后，我看着另一位女病理学家从沙漠中发现的脊柱上收集蛆虫。还有一个腐烂的头颅，下班前，她计划把它煮开，研究暴露出来的颅骨是否有挫伤。我被要求把这个信息传达给首席法医。回头看，也许我应该更小心地选择措辞。“烧开水，”我告诉他，“下午5点进行老式煮头颅。”
It was, of course, the fear talking. That, and a pathetic desire to appear casual-- one of the gang. That evening, instead of returning to my hotel, I sat around with the transporters, one of whom had recently been ticketed for using the carpool lane and then argued, unsuccessfully, that the dead body he was carrying in the back constituted a second passenger.
当然，这是恐惧在作祟。还有一种可悲的想要显得随意的渴望——像个同伙。那天晚上，我没有回到酒店，而是和搬运工们坐在一起，其中一个人最近因使用拼车车道被开罚单，他争辩说，他车后载着的尸体构成了第二位乘客，但没成功。
It was just the four of us until around midnight, when a tipsy man in a Daytona Beach sweatshirt came to the front gate and asked for a tour. When told no, he gestured toward an idling car and got his girlfriend to ask. The young woman was lovely and flirtatious, and as she pressed herself against the bars, I imagined her lying upon an autopsy table, her organs piled in a glistening heap beside her. I now looked at everyone this way. And it worried me that I'd never be able to stop.
直到午夜左右，我们四个人都在那里，一个穿着代托纳海滩运动衫、微醺的男人来到前门请求参观。被拒绝后，他指向一辆空转的车，让他的女友来问。那个年轻女子可爱又风骚，当她紧贴着栅栏时，我幻想着她躺在解剖台上，器官堆在她身边闪闪发光。我现在看每个人都是这样。这让我担心我永远无法停止。
This was the consequence of seeing too much and understanding the horrible truth. No one is safe. The world is not manageable. The trick-or-treater may not be struck down on Halloween, but sooner or later, he is going to get it, as am I, and everyone I have ever cared about. It goes without saying that for the next few weeks, I was not much fun to live with. In early November, I returned home and repelled every single person I came into contact with. Gradually, though, my gloominess wore off. By Thanksgiving, I was imagining people naked rather than dead and naked. And this was an improvement.
这就是看到太多和理解恐怖真相的后果。没人是安全的。世界无法控制。捣蛋鬼可能不会在万圣节遇难，但迟早，他会遭殃，就像我，以及我关心过的每个人。不用说，接下来的几周，我很难相处。11月初，我回到家，拒绝了与我接触的每一个人。但渐渐地，我的忧郁感消退了。到了感恩节，我开始想象人们裸体的样子，而不是死掉的裸体。这是一个进步。
A week later, I was back to smoking in bed. And just as I thought that I'd put it all behind me, I went to my neighborhood grocery store and saw an elderly woman slip on a grape. She fell hard. And after running to her side, I took her by the arm. "You really have to watch yourself in this produce aisle." I know it, she said. "I could have broken my leg." "Actually," I told her, "you could have been killed." The woman attempted to stand, but I wouldn't let her. "I'm serious," I told her. "People die this way. I've seen it."
一周后，我又开始在床上抽烟。就在我以为我已经把一切抛在脑后时，我去家附近的超市，看到一位老妇人在葡萄上滑倒了。她摔得很重。我跑过去扶住她的胳膊。“在果蔬区你真的要小心。”“我知道，”她说，“我差点断了腿。”“其实，”我告诉她，“你差点没命了。”那个女人试图站起来，但我没让她。“我是认真的，”我告诉她，“人就是这样死的。我见过。”
Her expression changed then and became fearful, rather than merely pain. It was the look you get when facing some sudden and insurmountable danger-- the errant truck, the shaky ladder, the crazy person who holds you too tight and insists with ever increasing urgency that everything you know and love can be undone by a grape.
她的表情变了，变得恐惧，而不仅仅是疼痛。那是面对突然且不可逾越的危险时才会有的表情——偏离轨道的卡车，摇晃的梯子，那个把你抓得太紧，并以越来越急迫的口吻坚持说你所知道和热爱的一切都会被一颗葡萄毁掉的疯子。
David Sedaris is the author of several books, most recently Calypso.
大卫·塞达里斯是多本书的作者，最近的作品是《Calypso》。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Marie and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for today's show was Julie Snyder. Additional production on the rerun from Jessica Lussenhopp, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Music help today from Jessica Hopper. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thank you, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who, he-- he-- he's coming up behind me.
好吧，我们的节目今天由简·玛丽和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。重播的额外制作由杰西卡·勒森霍普、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼完成。音乐支持来自杰西卡·霍珀。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生，他……他……他正从我后面走过来。
[HISSING]
[嘶嘶声]
No! Back next week, I hope, with more stories of This American Life.
不！希望下周回来时，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。